[INAUDIBLE].
[BEEPING]
We're here, yeah.
We're in Valdez.
It is 7:35.
We're five minutes behind.
Um, bluebird morning-- we
got some snow yesterday.
Gonna ride some lines
and do some flips.
It's going to be a good day.
[HELICOPTER ENGINE REVVING]
I was up in Alaska with my
crew working on this film,
"The Fourth Phase."
I think let's do this
wizard thing real quick.
It looks extremely good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAN (VOICEOVER): You need a
canvas to put your work on.
And the type of art
that I like to make
demands a very large canvas.
And that is Alaska.
You find snow features in
Alaska that you don't find
anywhere else in the world.
On my first couple trips,
I was really scared.
And scared not just on
a, I might get hurt,
but like there was
a death component.
You have cornices on the ridges.
You have crevasses.
There's a lot of big cliffs.
You get out of a helicopter
on top of a ridge.
And you look a couple
thousand feet down,
and there's an absolute
moment of leap of faith,
and then drop in and
surrender to the unknown.
Everything in your body is
like, speed check, speed check.
You're going too fast.
Slow down.
And you can't.
You have to just try to override
the body's natural ability
to protect itself.
[CHUCKLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Avalanches, of course, are
a constant thing that you're
thinking and talking about.
MAN: I've been skiing in the
big mountains for over 25 years.
And I've seen a lot
of bad things go down.
If you get caught
in an avalanche
on a big Alaskan face, you're
not stopping until the bottom.
MAN: All right, just do
a little snow check here.
OK.
With all these dangers,
why put yourself out there?
For me, riding in Alaska, it's
the art that I have worked
towards for so many years.
And all of the little
subtleties and the nuances
and the details, like,
that's where it matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]